well welcome everyone to the secret life
of pawns
I've prepared a bunch of different
material today and it's going to be a
lot of puzzles so there will be a lot of
times where I'll have you guys think for
an extended period of time
if you're watching on YouTube there will
be many times where I'll say just
positive video and I'm try and find the
solution so I've had this puzzle up for
a little bit now this is white to move
and it's white to move in win I know you
already know the winning idea right
does anyone else know or have seen this
sort of pattern before for a white no
okay that's good
this is this position I'll go ahead and
say it it looks just about crushing I
mean white has upon nb7
Queen on v6 rook on c1 this King is
blockading on b8
Kings are not known to be the best black
haters but it turns out this is not so
easy to win and white has to be very
precise and very accurate with with the
continuation and I will also say that
there's only one winning move in this
position everything else for white
doesn't work but I'll let you guys think
I'll look maybe give just a minute or
two and if no one can find it then I'll
call him Ashish okay I think you see it
okay what do you think
rook c8 what if rook takes see it's
queen a7 you're giving away your rook
and then your queen king take a seven
Wow very nice
have you seen this before oh that's
awesome
I've shown this to a lot of students who
haven't seen this before and it takes
them forever it I was pretty incredible
but but yeah this is this is actually
the only way to win yeah interesting so
you only kind of transpose or liquidate
down into a King pawn ending so yeah
this actually becomes some sort of
calculation where yeah white scheme
looks active but I don't think you're
gonna penetrate in time cuz King let's
say King III black can can keep
opposition maybe the safest move to play
as king e7 to keep long-distance
opposition and then wherever you go if
you try to move up then black will
maintain opposition this should just be
the draw so now that was an idea but
didn't quite work there's another idea
here which I want to go ahead and show
because it it looks winning at first it
requires less creativity than finding
this Knight promotion it's to play rook
a1 with the threat of rook e8 a question
here is how how does black survive
there's actually a really nice way for
black to to not lose this position
yeah you want to sit yeah because of the
black king is in stalemates or has no
legal moves then black can sacrifice the
rook and the Queen by force so the
drawing move would be rook t1
it's nice move and if rook take t1 then
Queen e1 and rook take you on and then
it's just a draw so this is sometimes a
funny way to survive when you're in a
very dire situation if you realize you
have like just a rook or a queen left
that is the only piece that can move if
you can sacrifice it by force like this
it can can lead to a miracle safe so I
wanted to use this problem as kind of
the introduction to this lecture because
the theme for today will be under
promotion because most of the time in
chess when you promote to upon you
promote to a queen but we're gonna take
a look at the scenarios where it's
better to promote to another piece
rather than a queen and there's a famous
quote in chess which I wanted to show a
picture here famous quote is every pawn
is a potential Queen but in this lecture
the quote is going to be every pawn is a
potential Knight Bishop rook okay so
with that we'll move on and let's go to
sorry let me minimize all my windows
first let me go back to the database
let's go to this one this is an
interesting one and what I shouldn't
mention there there's usually just two
reasons why you would want to under
promote in a game first reason is what
we just saw where a knight has a
different movement than the Queen and in
the last example was just a fork the
other reason to under promotes is to
avoid stalemate because the Queen is so
powerful in some cases if you promote to
a queen at stalemates which
especially in this case we can see that
if light promotes the queen of stalemate
white wants to win so the question is
how can white win from this position
I'll give you some time to think at home
feel free to to pause the video white to
move okay
oh geez I'll promote to a night with
Jackie let's calculate so b8 night King
bee 797 King CH now that six King take
d8 and I take h7 kingi seven
probably Knight g5 King f6 h 7 King g7
okay let me play it out on the board
this is probably the first one of the
first lines to consider a line that just
mentioned we promote tonight to avoid
stalemate the void king avoiding king
take p7 as well the problem for whites
is that the knight kind of got stuck and
why it is is losing back a piece here
because the knight the only safe Square
from the knight is d7 and then after
King C and it's a fork and then the
question becomes you want to save your
neither the vision and it turns out I'll
just go ahead and say just just right
away that this is already a draw if you
save your bishop it's a draw if you save
your knight it's a draw and to
demonstrate both instances let's start
with this variation 906 because white is
winning the plug the reason why this is
a draw is because black has not only the
very powerful outside past a pawn that
can act as a decoy but also because
White's King is a bit out of play and
relaxing is much closer to to the h6
pawn so black can simply play king e7
here and I think this is around where
you were kind of falling off with your
calculations but after Knight g5 black
does have to be careful does it move
like King f8 I don't think is effective
but black has king to f6 and after King
f6 the threat is King g6 right
white will have to play h7 at some
points and then the problem with this
position is that when the pawn lands on
h7 there's actually no way to win even
if white wins is a pawn and I mean we
could play this out to demonstrate like
let's say white goes ahead wins a pawn
try and play quickly here and then black
and there's in a very easy situation all
black has to do is move back and forth
and there's no way for white to make
progress whenever white tries to defend
the pawn with a king
it'll be stalemate if the knight moves
away from defending upon then just can't
engage seven
does that make sense to everyone so
unfortunately saving the knight doesn't
quite work out and if we go back to this
moment let's say white saves a bishop
and play as a move like Bishop a5 now
this is a little bit weird because
usually when you have a bishop and you
have a pawn like a rook pawn that's
going to Queen if the rook pawn has a
queening square of the same color as a
bishop then then it should be winning
for whites the problem is that the h7
pawn is very hard to win in this
position and if we play this out just to
demonstrate it's pretty easy for black
all black has to do is go and defend and
and this is a draw with without too much
trouble now I will say there is one
trick in this position it is possible
for white to it maybe you've seen it
before so there there is a trick in this
position if if white plays a move let's
say it's blacks move let's say a black
plays here and okay let's say black
gives away the pawn with a five then
there's King f7 and this is a one thing
black has to be concerned about is is
king f7 with discovered checkmate
so black would have to play and move
like King to g8 and as long as the King
doesn't walk into this mating idea it
should be an easy
just to demonstrate even further let's
say Bach actually gives away the pawn in
this case let's say King here here here
and now let's say Bishop c3 black to
moved you play King h8 or King f8 yeah
of course King f8 I've seen this
actually happened once in the game where
like the player was just moving back and
forth between h8 and g8 and didn't
realize this pattern and then just got
made it so you have to be very careful
in this situation is black when when
you're given the choice don't walk into
mates so let's go back this position
requires a bit of process of elimination
where guy helped you guys out there but
we can essentially eliminate promoting
tonight because none of these lines work
after after black manages King c8 so
what else can we try in this position
yeah the bishop is on the last piece
left right now what difference does a
bishop make because again black will
have the same idea of just walking
straight to to g8 you have to darks for
bishops which doesn't happen too often
in chess but is there a difference is
there a way like can can possibly win
this
so it's somewhat of a race right because
King got three King c8 and if you want
to accelerate your King you can get to
this point but this doesn't quite work
right
your Kings too slow and now it's boxed
out so this position takes some kind of
long-term understanding and the the key
thing to understand is that to
dark-squared bishop s'
plus this combination of h6 pawn versus
h7 pawn is winning for whites for a very
specific reason do you guys remember in
that the previous position I showed
where there is a the difference between
the King going to f8 & h8 what if we got
the same position but used one of the
bishops to control f8 and the other
bishop to setup the mating idea after
King h8 so now once you see the idea
then it's a matter of just executing so
it's actually pretty simple like once
you know the idea just make sure you're
not losing a bishop just save it the
black king will over on the run to the
Kings side and all I has to do let's
let's walk in the King Black's gonna lay
it around it doesn't really matter if
that gives away the a pawn let's say
King here a4 King f6 let's say a three
bishop take a three all we need to do is
have the bishops like this after King g8
we can simply play a waiting move just
move move the bishop anywhere along the
same diagonal and now it's Force King h8
and King f7 mates
so it wasn't so easy and it took it took
this kind of understanding of this final
position in order to realize that that
promoting to a bishop in this position
is only move leading to a win so this is
one of the harder problems but does that
sort of make sense to everyone
helps us sometimes play through it a few
times and I can encourage players if
you're not entirely sure to just
practice this like against a computer
and try and play that to win as whites
but let's move on so so far we've seen
promoting to a knight and promoting to a
bishop of several more examples this is
an interesting one this is not
necessarily finding the the winning
continuation it's just a matter of
evaluating the the result with best play
from both sides and this is a seemingly
simple King pawn ending this is white to
move and before I call on anyone the
first move for white should be very
simple like there's only one logical
first move the question is what is black
going to do after that and it's white
going to win is black going to win is it
going to be a draw so do you have an
idea ok so you see like the first key
idea this is a it's an important thing
to calculate and I'm not going to move
the pieces here because calculation is
important so I will draw arrows just to
demonstrate so you set a 7 B b1 equals
Queen and then if a 8 equals Queen Black
has a really nice saving resource to
play King B for say Queen B 7 King C 3
and after Queen take B one can imagine
that final position at stalemate black
has no no legal moves
it's an incredible stalemate with the
King on C 3 pretty close to the center
so just to play that out
King before queen bee 7/8 III game is
over it's a draw so you followed up
pretty nicely is that like an promotes
not to a queen but to a rook and this
prevents of stalemate because after king
d4 rook b8 king c3 the king has access
to c2 and then it's just an easy win for
white if King c2 that's the best way to
win maybe a move like rook g1 just get
to the second rank and if you're here
white will very soon pick up the pot
just to demonstrate even further
King bee to accede to rook g2 then Plan
C - Kim D 3 we have not come to the the
full conclusion yet though let me go
back to the very starting position
we know white is going to play a 7 so
play that first move it turns out that
black has a way to survive here a fact
recognizes this under promotion the idea
that white wants to firmly promote to a
rook black actually has a way here to
kind of circumvent that and still draw
the game so black to move yeah
King before first it's very nice kind of
a switch and move order the facts that
now if Y promotes to a queen that's
going to be the same idea as we saw
before where white has nothing better
than still meeting and we play King
before here because after white promotes
to a rook black is actually winning
black doesn't need to promote to a queen
the rook is actually inferior to these
two connected pass pawns and it's black
who's actually winning this so white
would have to be careful before
promoting to the rook not to allow this
because it's yeah there's there's no way
to stop the pawns it to be a check just
King c4 and if rook see a check probably
just king d5 and the king can run away
at the puns do the dirty work you have
to see many different layers like first
you have to see if both sides Queen it's
a draw but that if black Queens too
early it's it's winning if you under
promote and then then white has to
realize that under promoting after King
b4 is losing so the best path forward
here for a white that's just to accept
the the stalemates
after v1 Queen and the game with perfect
play it should end like this so any
questions about that think we'll move on
okay this next one is a fun one it's
very clear why it wants to take the
bishop
but when you take the bishop you still
have what for legal moves to choose
between so the question is when you take
the bishop what piece should you promote
to and I want to turn this into a poll
so I'll let you guys think for about a
minute and then we'll take a poll if you
should promote to a bishop a knight a
rook or a queen okay
okay time for a poll who would want to
promote to a queen who wants to promote
to a rook who wants to promote to a
Knights three people who wants to
promote to a bishop four people Wow so
we're split between Knight and Bishop as
far as I know there's only one winning
move let's start with promoting to a
knight what happens after King G 896
politics
King tix King F it's huge southern king
of seven
I don't think this is winning probably
just a draw but there's no way for a
white scheme to actually infiltrates so
congratulations
whoever said promoting to a bishop only
winning move when we promote to a bishop
where we're holding on to the bishop and
we're gonna win all the pawns very
easily just to demonstrate this the
bishop doesn't get trapped because of
Bishop g7 the knight was the one getting
trapped in which we did not want to
allow after Bishop g7 black is going to
be in basically perpetual as and so on
we're at like most every move for a
black is conceding squares black has to
give away the h7 pawn and then the King
will have to run to e8 and then White's
King comes in very easily and then now
white will pick up both a pawns and and
just win the game without any problems
make sense so sometimes you have to you
have to be aware of the critical moment
like here it was a very critical moment
choosing between Bishop and night and it
took some some calculation some
understanding to realize bishop is only
winning move okay let's move on next
position it's a bit more complex
now the funny thing about this position
is she do I want to say I'm not going to
say there's something funny about this
position which maybe some of you will
recognize all I will say is white to
move and win
yes rook c8 kim taek's yates 7 king goes
back to the corner can you see 7
ah you have to learn from the last
example though so we have actually the
same exact position but kind of mirrored
and yet you don't want to promote
tonight but if you promote to Bishop
again this is the same thing this is
winning but nice job for for getting
into that line of course these these
scenarios are quite uncommon and they're
pretty unlikely tapping in your own
games but the process of calculating and
evaluating what's winning and what's not
not working is is quite important yeah
b7 immediately the problem is your rook
is hanging so I don't think this is
quite working out and you're not gonna
put black and then any sort of looks
wrong these two pawns exist so I'm
pretty sure rook c8 is only only winning
move like you sack your rook and then
you eventually promote to a bishop
pretty beautiful way to it any questions
about this let's move on we're about
halfway through the positions this next
one's a pretty cool one this kind of
blew my mind I stumbled upon this
position earlier this is white to move
and when I first saw this position I
thought oh this is just dead lost I mean
the King blockades these two these two H
pawns and this G plows just going to
Queen I wouldn't be surprised if like
this happened in the game if the white
player would resign here because it it
looks very hopeless but this is white to
move and draw you wanna yeah you wanna
sit
okay let's play it out king g 6g 4g 3g -
so you have the right idea if only you
could get this position with black to
move right yeah so we'll go back but
just just to demonstrate like this
position is losing for white because
your King has to move here and then
black promotes to queen with check if it
were blacks move promoting to a queen or
rook would be stalemate
so let's go back what you want to do g4
h7g three
kingi five is uh is a hopeful move
hoping for g2 and then King age six this
would be a draw
unfortunately there's can take age seven
here and this pawn is still unstoppable
and you have no more tricks so you have
exactly the right idea you just need the
right execution so King f6 first this is
the only way to win you had to
essentially lose a tempo before going to
g6 you move to ff6 and then g6 so it's a
forcing move we hit the pawn g4 will be
played and now King g6 if g3 h7g to king
h6 even though this isn't necessarily
like under promotion because any any
promotion for black is a draw this just
demonstrates that there's some scenarios
where it doesn't matter what you promote
to it's just it's a draw if you promote
to queen or rook because it's stalemate
and if you promote to now your Bishop
it's just not enough material to mate
with
however if this one this isn't like an
online boots game or bowling game then
you want to play on and you want to
promote to an either Bishop because if
your opponent Flags I'm pretty sure both
servers on me chess and chess calm will
declare a win for black if white runs
out of time in a situation like this
because there's a possible checkmate
but if you're white just make sure you
don't flag it'll be a draw so anyway one
more line to demonstrate after King f6g
for King g6 what should white play after
black plays King g8
maybe trying to confuse you a little bit
okay yes so there's two candidate lives
there's h7 and King g5 what do you want
to say I'm pretty sure King g5 is the
only way to to draw is if we play h7
King h8 King h6 oh wait a minute this is
also drawn yeah I probably both moves
are drawn then King g5 is maybe a bit
more forcing King ji v g3 King g6 yeah
both of these are drawn because the King
has to move to h8 we moved to h6 but
from the beginning I think this is a
great demonstration of like calculation
is so important is in order to decide
between King f6 or King g6 you need to
calculate base with a full variation to
see if the timing works out for the
stalemate okay let's move on
we have about 23 minutes left
if 7 problems left let's go on to this
one this is white to move give some time
for the position to kind of sink in this
Jeep on is as a path to Queen so white
is in pretty grave danger also the rooks
attacked but I think this this position
again applies to a lot of ideas that
we've already seen
sheesh you're killing it with finding
the answers to every every problem we
give at least 30 seconds for for people
to think you're black to move or sorry
white to move and find the best response
okay
adi you can go first rook you once so
you're stopping the pun but you're
losing your rook rook you want Bishop
taking one King h3 so now you're
essentially you're forcing the pawn to
promote if the pawn promotes two rook or
queen it's just stalemate right question
is can black win the game by under
promoting so you're saying no yeah it's
similar to the position last time right
where if you promote - yeah and you're
exactly right if you promote tonight
then the knight is essentially trapped
it has to go to e2 and then there's a
fork if you promote to dark squared
Bishop this is a this is some essential
chess knowledge can black checkmate with
two bishops it depends if both bishops
are in the same color black cannot
checkmate with two dark straight bishops
there's not even like a possible
checkmate you can create with just King
and two bishops against King but because
White has a pond maybe there'd be some
like helpmates where if White was trying
to get me that it would be possible but
no this is just a dead draw so this is
another example where like black could
try and under promote but nothing worked
out and this idea of stalemate was
really nice for Mike to see this is
another position where I think a lot of
players might just resign or they might
play a move like rook got five check
which doesn't mean to anything and after
King e6 then it's soothing for whites so
let's move on to
okay we're probably going to have time
for all of these so this is another one
the kind of an interesting composition
this is white to move there's a couple
of things to realize here first thing
you should instantly realize is whites
in check so you have to find how white
can get out of check so I think second
thing to realize is that this pawn is
one square away from queening and you
should also realize that wherever the
white King goes black is ready to play
rook c5 obstructing White's rook and
allowing the pawn to promote so this is
another case where it looks like white
is going to be just losing because King
moves anywhere rook c5 black ball
promotes but you have to use some
creativity and it is white to move and
draw
okay let's hear it addy so king d4 rook
c5 pawn takes e5
and if I promotes to what good question
if I promote to a queen
it's still me if I promote to a rook
well if I promote to a bishop
so it's actually important where you
move your king but you found okay you
found the start of the critical line
I'll play this out king D for this is
the only drawing move black will play
rook c5 you take on c5 pawn takes e5 and
now incredible move King d3 attacking
the pawn if the pawn promotes in this
case to a rook or a queen is still means
if the pawn promotes to we were testing
off Bishop now you have to be very
careful if you played but if you play
King c2 this is probably just losing
after Bishop e3 so what's the what's the
best move for like King c4 you attack
the pawn forcing Bishop a3 and now a
simple drawing move anyone yet just d4
and you trade off blacks only pawn and I
guess there's one more line in fact
promotes to a Knights a same thing yeah
just King c4 it's easier this time given
that the Knights Knight is ineffective
in defending the pawn yeah that's a good
question if ur cage for a check we can
simply move back to d3 and we'll win the
pot and this should be an easy draw
given that the pawn can be progress so
like if you have this in a game and
you're black and you're c5 is probably
the best shot to try and win if white
doesn't see this idea but it's
unfortunate for a black because if this
king is like away from f3 I give it fun
some other random square like g2 it
would be winning because the King would
be helping contribute to the stalemate
in this
in this time black would love the king
anywhere else but f3 so let's move on
ah this is a fun one it's possible that
some of you may have seen this one
before this is a completely kind of
made-up position and the beauty in this
position white is going to under
promotes several times this is white to
move and wind actually wait it's yeah
this white to move in this position only
one winning move for white you've seen
this before okay then you're not allowed
to to answer anything you've seen this
before - okay so we need someone else
apart from magician Adi Java was that a
hand raised uh-huh so you've seen it but
you don't remember it okay this is
pretty memorable it might take a couple
of times until it's like it's ingrained
in your memory but did someone already
do this in a st. Louis chess club
lecture oh man so it's possible like the
whole YouTube audience has seen this
before - okay let's go through quickly
and then I'll just show the beauty is H
8 equals Knights and what happens is
black stalemates himself we have white
just plays so I move like and I take f7
stalemate and this was a problem with
promoting to a queen is that the Queen
had no great way to make progress but
the amazing thing is like an unstated by
playing Knight g6 and for this whole
sequence black is forced to play only
moves half take g6 is only move g5 is
only move and again
white promotes to a Knight g4 only move
96 pawn to g6 and the pattern continues
again we promote tonight's and again we
sacrifice the Knights take take and then
this still required some calculation
from the start because you if you know
you're going to get this position you
have to make sure that blocks not mating
you before your mating the King on each
one but fortunately the knight actually
attack the King very quickly here after
Knight d6 be to let's say Knight f5 b1
and then checkmate so it's a pretty
incredible solution
it was just force maiden in 14 given
that every single move black plate
wasn't only moved I guess with the
exception of the final move back had
four different options in the position
but nothing works
just out of curiosity I wonder at the
computer I was gonna see if the engine
can solve this let's see crafty because
crafty is usually like the weakest one
crafty solvent Wow crafty solves it it
sees a winning advantage doesn't see
force mate oh now it sees force mate
okay
if crafty can solve it then probably
every engine consultant okay so that was
a nice one let's move on from that
mm yeah let's do this one this is this
is white to move this is a bit more
realistic especially compared to the
last position kind of simple ending
bishop in pawn versus Knight and this
requires calculation it's white to move
the first move should be very obvious
the ultimate question is is white
winning give you some time to think have
you seen this before then it should take
you longer than 15 seconds to say
something okay so with perfect play is
it winning for white or is it drunk it's
winning okay let's play that so you six
I'm repeating the moves you're saying
just so the online audience can hear so
II 6 dot F for Bishop da check King a 6
95 ok rotor rook
okay so you got it let me explain it for
everyone else yeah of course east six
first move we want to promote as quickly
as possible and to solve this this
position precisely you have to figure
out blacks of defensive resource this
case BOC has a nice resource to play
Knight f4 and a lot of players will
maybe get stuck around Tirek because if
white pushes the pawn again there's
Knight d5 and this is actually just a
draw the nice attacking the pawn if the
pawn promotes to queen or rook
there's Knight c7 with a fork if the
plum promotes to a knight then it's okay
Knight to f6 is just a draw so a bishop
to D a check first is a very important
kind of nuance to include this kind of
forcing move o Bishop D a check in this
position oh sorry in this position this
isn't as accurate because you're
allowing the King to move closer to the
pawn and the King is actually within
range this is probably just a draw
because then the night will come back so
it's actually the timing is very
important that you play a six first and
then Bishop d8
but black has one last trick up his
sleeve
and black can play this sly move King
Asics and after a seven
as white you have to be hyper aware of
what's going on here because if you
carelessly promote to a queen the game
ends in a draw black to move yeah yeah
Knight c7 with a fork and if Bishop take
it's just domine
so nice little resource for black so
it's almost drawn that White has one
winning move and that move is to promote
to a rook now that night c7 no longer
working because Bishop take and it's not
stalemate and the bishop in rook versus
knight is an easy win so this is a nice
study with several different layers
where you had to kind of see the the
first initial line realizing that first
have to include Bishop d8 and then you
have to realize that that there's a
stalemate wreck and you circumvent that
with the with under promotion
okay so everything I've shown so far has
been pretty much an endgame study it's
been like composed hasn't necessarily
happened in a real game I want to show a
position which actually came from a real
game did anyone follow the protests
League back this last season started in
January on chess calm okay so one of the
most exciting games in the protest
League took place between John Ludwig
hammer and might screw this name up but
our two Art Tour nikons or knee cons and
there was a game had like amazing
fireworks I want to get to the key
position where hammer is playing black
white has just Queens or sorry hammer is
playing white so he just Queens and his
opponent has this combination of knights
rook and two pawns and amazingly enough
black is winning by force in this
position there's a mating net to use
both pawns the night
and the rook so I want to pose this as a
puzzle black to move and if I'm not
mistaken it's just forced mate in in a
few moves
I think the first move should be pretty
obvious right
just d3 yeah for sticking to move say
king d1 king d2 I should note doesn't
make or it doesn't help that much
because there's rook b2 and then there's
mating ideas of King III there's Ricky -
and if if King d1 the knight c3 and King
e1 and then we pushed the pawn and will
promotes easy win so after a d3 King d1
is played what to do next
and you know you have to basically
continue checking the Kings so there's
really only two checks to consider here
I'm 8c3 King D - so rook be one is the
better move yeah we're we're forcing the
King up and then then we have to we have
to start calculating because if you play
c3 you allow King take d3 and you're
probably going to run out of steam but
rook b2 this is a transposition right
what we just saw and again if King III
there's rookie two mates so hammer plays
King you won let's continue from here
yeah D - King you too
so wait you said promote in this
position if you promote here at King
take t1 right
ninety-three of course and now white is
in a pretty dire situation if King goes
to f1 or f2 there is D 1 equals Queen
and it's just just over so hammer played
King III and I'm pretty sure like after
the game hammer said he willingly went
into this line because he was aware that
there is some hope of survival but
before I get into that ok what what
should lack play in this position yeah
it's made in 1 D 1 equals Knight game
over this didn't happen in the game his
opponent first plays Knight D 1 check
King e2 repeats the position it's still
winning then his opponent proceeds to
take like 20 to 30 seconds to play the
next move and you guys might be aware of
this but when you play online there's a
setting on both chess calm and and and
unli chess
that's called Auto Queen is when you
have the setting turned on and you
promote it doesn't give you the option
of choosing the piece it just promotes
to a queen right away so what I heard
from at least from what I heard the
player playing black was trying to like
change the setting during the game but
he had a minute left and either he
couldn't figure out how to change it or
he did change it but he forgot to like
refresh the page to update it and he
ended up promoting to a queen because of
the Auto Queen setting which was just a
really unfortunate circumstance which is
something you kind of have to be aware
of when you play online chess for future
reference I found out about this not too
long ago but to avoid this scenario if
you know you have Auto Queen turned on
unfortunately don't have the sights up
to demonstrate but even if you hold down
the control key while promoting to a
queen it will then give you the option
it will basically temporarily disable
the auto queen option
so thank me later if you ever if you're
ever in a scenario where you have to
hold down control to avoid Auto Queen to
promote to a night with with mates what
have been nice for black to know but but
okay so the funny thing is that after
after this moment of D 1 equals queen
white is winning after Queen g7 King g6
hammer hammer has made in 3 in this
position and because we're running low
on time I'll maybe help you guys out
wait but I actually have to find the
main and three myself
where was the main in three oh yeah it's
you said Queen g7 Queen d7 King c5 King
before the king is running
pretty sure the maid is a five if King
see five then there's this nice queenie
seven move preventing the king from
running to d4 and the bishop and these
this pawn creates a wall for the king
after after the key moves back then
there's simply queen g6 mates and then
the other line if 'if i've king take e5
there's no king take e5 because queen
defense so let's say king d5 first then
there is Queen d7 if King c5 it's gonna
be the same man as we saw before with
Queen e7 and if King take e5 there is f4
King f6 only move and then Queen f7 mate
not easy sometimes when the Kings in the
center to make sure everything was
controlled around the King but all of
that would have been forcing but both
players were in time trouble and hammer
maybe freaked out a little bit and took
on c3 which is a terrible move this
loser loses instantly to to a simple pin
hopefully most of you see it rook be
three but black didn't play rook be
three black was so flustered from his
lack of ability to promote to a night
that he played a rookie to check and
then they entered this crazy ending
where it was Bishop and three pawns
against this this rook and past C pawn
but black eventually still prevailed the
C pawn got very far the bishop had to
sacrifice itself and then black played
very well just block he had the three
pawns and then when the a pond and there
is no no good way for white to make
progress from this position so white
just resigned
so it's a really cool cool moment which
hopefully provides lessons for for
anyone who plays online that you should
be aware of night promotion you want to
be aware of when although queen is
turned on as well so I think we'll end
it there thanks guys for watching and if
you're on YouTube and you have questions
just leave a comment below thanks
[Music]